he's up there accepting a award he says
I brought Mel Gibson here to uh with me
while I'm accepting this award he says
there's a reason why I brought Mel
Gibson him when I was going through my
mess Mel called me and we were speaking
and he says listen man whatever you do
go find your faith but it's got to be
your fate I don't care what it is but go
find your faith he says I respected the
fact that he told me to go find my faith
and I did and he says so then there's a
movie that while nobody's accepting me I
don't have any money I don't know how to
pay rent I have a hard time dropping
alcohol I have a hard time dropping
anything Mel gives me a role that he was
supposed to take but he gave it to me he
called me says this is for you he says
that itself helped me so much because it
allowed me to pay my bills during this
time and I did that and then next thing
you know my career takes off and I told
Mel how can I pay it back to you and you
know what Mel said when the next Robert
Downey Jr is going through this do it
for them again okay because somebody did
it for me
[Music]
[Applause]